um is there anybody who has tapped in
with you recently just like that you are
a fan of that you just found out was
like [ __ ] with your movement [ __ ]
with your music whether maybe someone
dm'd you or or you found out they are
listening to your music they're like you
were really kind of yesterday I was on
Instagram
I was when I was on YouTube I was
watching Crystal Castles like I was
watching them perform then I went to uh
the lead singer named Alex on their
Instagram she followed me on Instagram I
like oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] that really
did it for me because like my whole
inspiration right now because she
followed me so I'm like damn she I'm
sorry did you say Crooks and castles
Crystal Castles
horrible horrible clothing I'm talking
about the band crazy it used to be fire
back in there in the day Crooks and
castles was hard way back like 2006
Crooks and castles was that Christian
castles was like what you got when you
couldn't afford like diamond in obeying
no no it was like the first [ __ ] was
Crooks 10 Deep and then Diamond came on
10 Deep I rather 10 Deep and then what's
the one that had the hundreds the
hundreds yeah the hundreds yeah the
hundreds that [ __ ] was hard Crooks and
castles was like I feel like that was
like back in like that's what you got if
you couldn't get like yeah there was
some real like off-brand ass streetwear
where you were like oh you got that at
Ross didn't you exactly it wasn't
crooked but it was some [ __ ] there was
some [ __ ] that you were like oh I see oh
yeah where would you say you draw from
uh inspiration wise for your fashion
uh like I don't know just like really
expressing like what the [ __ ] I want to
look like I'd be waking up every day
thinking I'm like a character so I just
be trying to be whatever [ __ ] character
I want to be and like
I don't know
I told them that this my band jacket so
um
you got the Bain record
would you uh well first of all
I always talk about what's the best
Batman movie yeah I'm Dark Knight 100 I
agree but I do think that Robert
Pattinson one is like in the running for
like two or three I fell asleep every
time I watched that one really I can't
get through that [ __ ] it's fire I'm not
saying it's bad I really do actually
think I like it but always fall asleep
well you think you like it but you fall
so you obviously don't like it it's
obviously not catching your [ __ ]
attention and or you smoke too much
before you watched it that'd be the
problem for real it would be slow and
quiet and calm so I just be like